咱们刚才加了一节课啊，给大家讲一讲格式。好吧，这个格式这玩意儿啊现在讲有点早了。
但是很多人想知道，那就说了。
现在开始。
我给大家回到我们剧本的顺序。之前我给大家讲过故事八要素，我也不止大家写了，我说写1个1000字到2000字，1500左右吧，写一个包含八要素的。
故事。
那是个什么玩意儿？
我当时为什么让大家写那个东西啊？那个东西是个梗盖。
也就是说，你们如果好好的完成作业了。
做了八要素的那件事情了，你们现在手里的那个东西叫个梗盖。
好吧，这个梗盖这个故事呢。
变成剧本。
中间隔着一个玩意儿叫大纲。
也就是说我们写剧本的时候啊。
呃，一般的顺序是先有个创意。
先有个创意。
我给大家讲过创意从哪下手，对吧？我们有5个地方可以下可以下手搞创意的。
然后呢把创意搞成梗概。
梗盖再做成大纲，大纲做成剧本。
大纲呢一般是我们是叫万字钢嘛，一般是一万字左右。所以我们叫它万字钢。
所以这这节课。
我教大家写这个玩意儿。
好了，把你的梗盖八要素的梗盖。
写成万字钢。
这句话说完了，我能隔着屏幕感觉到有些同学在叹气，为什么？
不是说好了，写剧本吗？我说很着急呀，老师，你让我写半小时，我老老实实写了，你告诉我有了故事，故事是剧本的原材料，我们开始搞剧本了，为什么又要搞一个刚？
还是个万字纲，你早说要需要一个刚，我上次写梗概的时候，我就把那2000字1500字，我努一努扩成1万，我描写的详细一点，扩成一万不就完了吗？
定不是这么个事儿啊。
我把今天的课讲一下，你就知道区别在哪。
大纲和梗盖的区别不是字儿的区别。大纲写完变成剧本就非常简单了。大纲可离剧本更近。
梗盖到大纲有一个质的飞跃，质的区别。
所以咱这节课讲什么呢？
就是大纲是什么玩意儿呢？这节课叫拿事儿说话。
在呀。
你有八要素，你咋描述，那是你的事。到大纲这里到万字钢这里，我就提这个要求。
你给我拿事儿说话。
你们现在扒拉扒拉你们自己手里的大纲，你瞅一瞅。
有很多描述性的东西。
比如说啥。
我给你举个例子啊。
比如说假设这个主角叫老李。
老李是一个。
外表冷淡，内心狂热的人儿。
有没有这种话差不多有。
类似的话。
你写的很过瘾，你觉得哎你看我这个人物还挺立体，挺矛盾的啊，外表冷漠，内心狂热。哎呀呀呀，挺好。这个人来，我告诉你，你最后在剧本当中。
我他妈我观众怎么可能知道你外表冷漠，内心狂热呢？
是不是这么个道理？
你说他外表冷漠，内心狂热。
那是写小说的写法。
明白吗？你在小说里在作文里写，老李是一个外表冷漠，内心狂热的人。
观众就懂了啊，就你的读者就懂了。
他他他理解这个事儿了。但是在我们的剧本里面。
你告诉我，你是通过什么机会告诉你的观众，老李外表冷漠，内心狂热。
那观众没有机会知道，除非什么。
你给我拿事儿说话。
所以这一步为什么我说是智的飞跃？
你梗盖里面可以这么写。
到万字钢，这些东西全部给我。
变成事儿。
否则就没有这个否则就没了。
你前面描述的梗概里描述分儿好，老李外表冷漠，内心狂热，到万字钢里，你不用事儿，你不通过一件事儿。
把这个交代了，那这个就没了。
这个设定就没了。
无效无效，所有的有效的东西都是拿事说话。
明白吗？
所以说梗改到万子钢。
智的飞跃是什么？
事儿就是事儿实践。
比如说假设啊假设你这个老李是个主角。
然后呢，他的外表冷漠，内心狂热，是他的主要设定。那你必基本上你第一场戏你就得把这个办了。
你就得把这个事儿办了，必须用事儿。有些同学说那。
没有合适的事儿，那我不能用台词说吗？
老李碰到老王说，哎，老王，你好，我叫老李。我这个人吧，外表冷漠，内心狂热。
是吧老王说啊，这么巧，我呢是怎么回事？外表嘻嘻哈哈，内心很踏实。
有这么说话的吗？对吧？
这观众也不买大呀。
所以必须通过事儿说话啊，我说咱这一课写成万字纲肯定是有意义的。然后拿事说话，大家现在明白了，然后又突然陷入另外一种迷茫，就是说我能妈哪有那么多事儿。
没关系啊，上这节课不就是讲这个的吗？
拿事儿说话。
怎么样构建这个事儿，怎么样写这个万字纲，怎么样用事儿去把你的这些想表达东西表达出来。那我们就先来看这个。
万字钢里。
你这个基本格式，我们说。
叫。
三木。
三幕式格式。
基本格式是商务式格式啊应该是。
很古老的一种说法了，木嘛从戏剧那儿来的，基本上就是那些祖宗级的。
呃，亚里士多德。
莎士比亚是他们那开启定义的这个这种这种模式。
哪三步呢？
第一幕叫。
建制。
然后第二步叫对抗。
第三步叫解决。
限制对抗解决啥意思呢？先构建这个世界，构建这个环境，构建这些人物。
前提给搞成。
然后呢，就进入对抗。
各种对抗辣锯。
然后最后。
事情。
何去何从？
就是三步式。
如果是我们以电影为电影举例，假设1个100分钟的电影。
那就是。
255025。
基本上啊是这么一个篇幅配置。所以你看这这个50其实是可以一拆二的，就是这个对抗。
是可以一拆二的，拆成推进。
和转折。
也就是说，建制推进转折25。
呃，在解决。
建制推进转折解决。
各25。
那这样分的就比较细了。
是吧四等分啊。
所以你看啊还有些书上喜欢写四式。
有写有写四幕式啊，四模式就是三幕式。
啊，一样的就是这么一个分，而且分成四目式之后啊。
就与我们中华文明的启承转合。
不谋而合了。
你看建制不就是起吗？
推进不就是成吗？
转折不就是转吗？
解决不就正好是和吗？
就是咱们的启程转壳。
四个部分。
有些同学就问了，你不是要教我们拿事儿说话吗？
我们本来就有点发懵，然后你给我们一讲这个三幕式四目式啊。
彻底把我们给。
带懵了，别懵，我为什么要给你们讲？
三幕式四幕式呢就是要给你们讲一下事儿放在哪儿好吧，来。
我们用私慕式的这几个词来。
来讲吧。
我给你们写一下啊。
字幕式的话，那就是建制。
推进。
转折。
解决。
也就是说，这一个线性的故事是不是分成了四段呢？
也就是说，把这个各25分钟的一个戏分成了四段呢。
我们说一个戏一个剧本里，或者说叫一个万字纲里，必须要拿事儿说话，对吧？拿事儿说话的话，那分成四段。
我打了三个点，这三个点上分别是什么？
三个事儿。
分别是三个事儿。
我们说第一个事儿。
叫激励事件嘿。
哎，是吧开始没那么上火了吧。
激励事件。
第二个事儿叫转折事件。
第三个事儿叫危机事件。
然后这三个点分别是三件事情来。
做到。
推进从起到成拉，从成到转拉，从转到合了，起成转合嘛三件事情。然后我是不是说过开场必须用时间？
这里有个一个叫开场事件。
又是一个事件。
然后解决完了之后，最后这里这个事件叫什么呢？
高潮世件。
有些同学在这里有个小小的疑虑，都结束了，怎么还高潮呢？我跟你说，电影的高潮就在。
明白吗？结束就是高潮。
所有的炸弹爆炸了，英雄咣咣咣出来了，就是高潮即结束，懂吗？很多事情高潮就是结束，你们不明白吗？是吧？高潮事件在在最后的。
所以你看啊。
私目式这个故事结构分成四个部分，四个部分打点的话，是不是打出5个点？
这5个点分别是5个事儿。
分别是5个事啊。
你要写一个开场的事件，再写一个激励的事件。
再写一个转折的事件，转折的事件啊一般是什么事件啊？
般是一次动作，失败之后要干二次动作。一般啊。
这个不是教科书上说的，是我说的，你们心里有点数，我怕你们理解不了什么叫转折事件。
就事情开始起变变化了。
危机事件。
就最后要搞死人的那一下危机事件。
高潮事件就是主角怎么把这个事件解决的？
怎么样绝对大反击他？
学吗？
所以你看。
这个思募式。
就给我们提供了5个事件。
你需要在这个5个世界里面。
以这5个基本事件。
为骨架把这个万字钢做出来。
有些同学又要。
产生疑虑了。
说。
你之前跟我们说的好好的。
说故事分为八要素。
让我们把八要素从头到尾捋完了就有故事了。
你现在出尔反。
又跟我们说有5个事件。
同学们有点懵了。
不要蒙。
我八要素的时候，我让你们写的是梗概呀。
你梗盖里面写。
老李他，我也比较冷漠，内心狂热。我当时我也没说你什么呀。
因为它可以出现在梗盖里面，你懂我意思吗？
你的梗盖里面有一个说这个警察想要殉职。
这是描述，没有问题。
没有问题。
但是在这里它就是一个开场事件呀。
想要殉职，你得给我做出来呀，你不能说哎他想要殉职，他想要殉职啊，他想要殉职都是街街上的传闻吗？还是还是谁给说出来了？不行啊，就是这个事儿。所以第一件事情开场事件就是他殉职，他在那想就找死，明白这个意思吗？
所以说那个八要素是什么啊？它是八要素，是你写梗概。
大要素。
现在我让你写大纲。
按照这个事件顺序给我写。
有些同学就说，那之前你早说这个我们从这儿开始多好，那8要素有啥用？8要4有用的。
八要素是纵轴。
这不是个横轴吗？
这一刻开始就是这些这些内容啊稍微有点搞脑子了。
大家仔细听仔细体会，不行，就多听几遍，听不明白的多问，有点搞脑子也正常，一点都不搞脑子，那那还学啥一点都不搞脑子，谁都一看就就就能会。那这行也。
也没意思了吧，对吧？
我们说八要素啊，人物。
他的身份。
他的欲望。
然后他的动作。
然后事件的这些呃问题。
主力。
解决。
结果。
然后主题。
的正负能量。我们说这些啊。
它是纵轴里面的。
人物在开场时间里面，他是一个什么状态？
对吧在激励世界里面。
他的身份在开场世件里面，他是一个身份。
对吧他是一个比如说开场那个想要殉斥的警察。
开场世界里面是一个警察。
然后到转折事件的时候。
他就变成了一个父亲了。
明白我意思吗？
就说纵轴还是八要素。
但是在横轴的五件事里面，你给他们找到他们各自。
发展的程度。
然后你看甚至连这个主题，这个正负价值开场事件的时候是负加值主导，因为他想死呀。
他想一死了之呀，那么他在什么时候的时候开始变成正价值主导？
就是你横轴上就要完成的事情。你在这五件大事儿里面。
需要解决的事情。
所以你可以把私目式。
五件股价事件，当然还有小事件啊，当中是有小事件的，到时候后面我会教大家细分咱们剧本这个阶段，咱们第二阶段的课程是最长的，是要最详细讲的。
我这里只是先给你讲。
整个大的股价。
五件事情作为。
横轴上的股价，然后你把你的。
八要素。
列为纵轴，然后在每一个小方块里面。
钱让他们的发展变化。
包括来欲望。
的发展变化在每个阶段。
动作的发展变化对吧？阻力的发展变化问题，这个悬念一直在变化，在5个事件中，然后你就会瞬间。
得到一张。
表格。
你的万字钢就有了。
其实就是你。
剧本里面所有要拿事儿说话。
你这些事儿啊。
都有了。
然后你写出来东西就不再会有那种。
一个外表冷漠，内心狂热的老李。
这种事情。
就不会有这种玩意儿。
他就是一个。
更接近于剧本的东西了。
明白了吗？
这节课先上到这儿。
我们下节课再详细说。
记住这个表格啊，自己回去比划比划。
好吧。
下课。